so I have a
2022 uh
Miata Club Edition which is her she
drives that around the RF version it's
got like a whole bunch of stuff I'm
actually giving that away it's got It's
lower it has suspension everything it's
all done up does it um I have a my dad's
86 uh C4 Corvette I saw that white yeah
the white one with the Greenwood body
kit that we would always like to talk
about and uh the black rag top
um so he's had that since 87. is it like
60 000 miles yeah all original I'm
giving that forever
um and then I bought him before he died
I bought him uh the the car that he
wanted which was a 2017 uh CTS-V
Cadillac oh those are sick yeah I love
those
um and then I have uh the TRX which I
have today because I couldn't come to
this podcast driving a Corolla that
would have hurt my face I felt
embarrassed so I was like I gotta take
the TRX hell yeah um and then I have a
two-door Jeep which is on the way